واعلن حزب الله اللبناني انه استهدف تجمعا
للجنود الاسرائيليين بالصواريخ جنوب
مستوطنه المناره وفي موقع المالكيه مؤكدا
تحقيق اصابات مباشره وقال الحزب ان
مقاتليه استهدفوا تجمعا لجنود العدو
الاسرائيلي في محيط موقع المطله واوقع بين
قتيل وجريح كما اعلن الحزب قصف موقع
الرادار الاسرائيلي في مزارع شبعه المحتله
وكان مراسل الجزيره قد افاد باطلاق سبعه
صواريخ من جنوب لبنان باتجاه مواقع عسكريه
اسرائيليه في الجليل الاعلى ومستوطن
المطله وقد دوت سفارات الانذار في كارات ش
مونا ومناطق عده في الجليل الاعلى في
السياق ذاته قال رئيس المجلس التنفيذي في
حزب الله ان استهداف قاعده ميرون امس ليس
كل الرد على اغتيال العاروري وان هناك
ردودا اضافيه على العدو ان ينتظرها على حد
قوله
وننوه مشاهدينا الى هذه الاخبار العاجله
حزب الله يقول استهدفنا تجمعا لجنود العدو
الاسرائيلي في محيط موقع المطله وا اوقعنا
بين قتيل
وجريح وايضا في هذا الخبر العاجل المتحدث
باسم الخارجيه الامريكيه يقول قطر شريك
مهم في الجهود الجاريه لاطلاق سراح
الرهائن في قطاع غزه اذا حزب الله كما
ذكرنا يقول استهدفنا تجمع لجنود العدو
الاسرائيلي بين او في محيط موقع المطله
واوقع نهم بين قتيل وجريح و للمزيد حول
هذا الموضوع معنا او قبل ذلك ايضا خبر عجل
اخر عن القناه الثانيه ع الاسرائيليه
اصابه مباشره لمنزل في بلده المطله بصاروخ
مضاد للدروع اطلق من جنوب لبنان وحزب الله
يقول انه استهدف بصواريخ كورنيت دبابه في
موقع رويسه العاصي ما ادى الى تدميرها
ومقتل وجرح طاقمها الان للمتابعه ينضم
الينا من ابل السقي في جنوب لبنان مراسل
الجزيره جوني طانيوس ومن الجليل الاعلى
مراسله الجزيره فاطمه خميسي ابدا معك جوني
واخر التطورات في الميدان وايضا هذه
التصريحات الاخيره لحزب
الله م شك فيه سهام ان التوتر والترقب هو
السائد هنا عند هذه الجبهه الجنوبيه
الحدوديه رغم ان وتيره التصعيد مقارنه بما
كانت عليه يوم امس هي اقل بعض الشيء
يمكننا الحديث عن مجموعه من المعطيات
الميدانيه ابرزها اعلان حزب الله عن
تنفيذه ست عمليات باتجاه مواقع عسكريه
اسرائيليه مختلفه من بينها موقع الرادار
العسكري الاسرائيلي في مزارع شبعه الذي
يقع خلفنا مباشره وتموضع للجنود
الاسرائيليين في مستوطنه المطل وغيرها من
الاماكن بالاضافه طبعا الى استهداف دبابه
بصاروخ من نوع كورنت في موقع رويسه العاصي
وقال حزب الله انه حقق اصابه مباشره هناك
ايضا معطيات ميدانيه اخرى اطلاق صواريخ من
الاراضي اللبنانيه باتجاه الجليل الاعلى
حتى هذه اللحظه لم تتبنى اي جهه المسؤوليه
عن اطلاق هذه الصواريخ ربما تكون هناك
بيانات ايضاحيه في المرحله المقبله على
مستوى الاعتداءات الاسرائيليه على الاراضي
اللبنانيه كانت هناك اليوم غارات على
منطقه اللبونه في القطاع الغربي وايضا
مسيره اسرائيليه اطلقت صاروخا باتجاه بلده
الهبريه غير البعيده من هنا بالاضافه الى
غارات وهميه صباحيه نفذتها ايضا المقاتلات
الحربيه الاسرائيليه فوق منطقه بنت جبيل
واثرت الذعر في صفوف المواطنين القصف
المدفعي لم يكن اقل عنفا باتجاه عدد كبير
من البلدات الحدوديه لليوم الثاني على
التوال
وجه الجانب الاسرائيلي القذائف الدخانيه
باتجاه بلده الخيان بشكل كثيف قبل نحو اقل
من ساعه طبعا هناك ترقب لمسار الامور في
المرحله المقبله خصوصا في ظل التصريحات
الصادره عن مسؤولين من حزب الله من بينهم
رئيس المجلس التنفيذي في الحزب هاشم صفي
الدين الذي قال ان استهداف قاعده التحكم
والمراقبه الجويه في جبل ميرون يوم امس
وهذه العمليه النوعيه التي نف حزب الله هو
جزء من الرد على عمليه اختار صح الع في
الضحيه وسيكون هناك مز استهدف سكنه شمير
بالاسلحه المناسبه وحقق فيها اصابات
مباشره وننتقل الان الى مراسلتنا في
الجليل الاعلى فاطمه خميسي فاطمه ما
الجديد فيما يخص الجانب
الاسرائيلي نعم في البدايه سهام ان سمحت
لي اود انا وزميلي المصور مجيد الصفدي ان
نتقدم با حر التعازي لزميلنا العزيز وائل
الدحدوح باستشهاد ابنه حمزه ونسال الله ان
يلهمه الصبره والسلوان بخصوص التطورات هنا
على الجبهه الشماليه من الناحيه الميدانيه
نتحدث عن دوي صفارات الانذار بشكل واسع
خلال الساعه الاخيره في كافه المناطق في
الجليل الاعلى نتحدث عن البلدات الحدوديه
الاسرائيليه من بينها ايضا مدينه كريات
شموني ووفق المعلومات الاوليه تم اصابه
فندق في بلده المطله بشكل مباشر بصاروخ
مضاد للدروع اطلق من الاراضي اللبنانيه
وايضا كان هنالك عمليات متتاليه وسريعه
شنها حزب الله باتجاه مواقع عسكريه
اسرائيليه نتحدث ايضا عن استهداف موقع
عسكري اسرائيلي في اعلى جبل الشيخ بثمانيه
صواريخ على الاقل وايضا كان هنالك استهداف
لمواقع اسرائيليه تابعه للجيش تقع ما بين
بلده المناره وبلده يفتاح في الجليل
الاعلى